standalone movies are so 1980s these
days it's rare for a movie to end
without laying the groundwork for some
sort of sequel or franchise
unfortunately a lot can change between
movies directors leave projects and
long-term priorities change all of which
can leave compelling cliffhangers to
dangle in the wind from replacement
spies vanishing between movies to
abandon apocalyptic endings here are a
few cliffhangers that movie sequels
ignored aw rats the original species
released in 1995 follows a group of
scientists trying to stop an alien-human
hybrid intent on breeding with humanity
while the scientists are able to
ultimately destroy the hybrid the movie
ends on a rat that's exhibiting some
strange behavior after eating the corpse
instead of following up on that plot
thread species - just doubles down on
the creepy erotic themes of the first
movie for train scientists trying to
stop a brand new mating obsessed
alien-human hybrid that hungry rat and
the implications that the genetic
mutation can be introduced through food
rather than intercourse is totally
ignored we'll never know what we missed
that's just corny what children of the
corn started as a simple Stephen King
short story about a group of kids in a
Midwestern town worshiping a demonic
entity it's cents spun into a massive
franchise with nearly ten movies and
Counting obviously that's required a bit
of an escalation from the original
premise which is what happens in
children of the corn three urban harvest
when two children of the corn are
adopted into foster care in Chicago they
bring corn
[Music]
that's nice-looking fun through a series
of violent events one of the children is
able to summon the demonic corn monster
to Chicago while also distributing
mind-controlling corn all over the world
an entire world of mind-control children
isn't a bad hook to hang a horror film
on unfortunately children of the corn
for The Gathering would return the
series to its roots as it were by taking
things back to the Midwest ignoring the
worldwide implications of the previous
film there was only one appropriate
reaction to the unrelated sequel a
missed call like children of the corn
the lawnmower man is so far removed from
the original story about a murderous
naked lawnmower man but King
successfully sued to remove his name
from the finished movie the film follows
Jobe a greenskeeper who becomes a
vengeful cyberspace God through a series
of science experiments halfway through
the film Jobe promises to prove his
godlike power by making every phone in
the world ring simultaneously once he's
achieved unlimited cybernetic control
[Music]
[Applause]
an omnipotent technology controlling
despots seems like a great place to
start a sequel but the lawnmower man to
beyond cyberspace features a largely new
group of characters in a cyberpunk Los
Angeles job makes his return as an
antagonist but using a different actor
his triumph in the first film is ignored
in favor of a redcon that left him
crippled by the climactic explosion in
the first lawnmower man born again as
one might guess given its title the
Bourne franchise is focused on The
Adventures of amnesiac assassin Jason
Bourne the formula worked so well that
even when Matt Damon took a hiatus from
the series it moved on without him for
2012's the Bourne Legacy following
Jeremy Renner as borns fellow spy Aaron
cross the film tried to capitalize on
the world-building of prior films with a
character similar to Jason Bourne and a
familiar story unfortunately for them
the movie premiered to mixed reviews and
a nimble and audience the filmmakers
heard that message loud and clear when
they completely ignored the ending of
the Bourne Legacy which featured cross
wounded after a shootout and a close
escape on a boat the next sequel Jason
Bourne forgets about any boat related
cliffhangers putting the focus squarely
back on Damon's character Dino do's and
dont's it's fitting for a movie
franchise about giant prehistoric
dinosaurs that each movie in the
Jurassic Park series tends to get bigger
even once a balance seems to be reached
by Jurassic Park 3 with the escape
dinosaurs settling on an island the film
ends with Pteranodons seeking out new
nesting grounds it's like dr. Ian
Malcolm always says life finds away
unfortunately the ending went too big as
cool as it would be to see dinosaurs out
in the world 2012 Jurassic world decided
to skip the whole dinosaurs terrorizing
the mainland thing and the fourth film
just returned to the original fully
functional Jurassic Park instead of
going bigger giving us very little
reason to well lost leader while it's
been somewhat forgotten 2008's The
Incredible Hulk is still an important
building block for modern-day Marvel
films while ed Norton's version of Bruce
Banner wouldn't make the jump to later
films William Hertz Thunderbolt Ross
would later return to the MCU for
Captain America Civil War further
connecting the movie to the larger MCU
is the ending sequence that features
Robert Downey jr. Tony Stark dropping
some foreshadowing for the Avengers
if I told you we were putting a team
together
who's we despite all that there's still
at least one cliffhanger that has never
been resolved Samuel Sterns irradiated
transformation into his big-headed comic
book counterpart the leader was the most
advanced mind the world has ever seen
the supervillain is one of the Hulk's
most famous foes so it makes sense that
the filmmakers would want to tease his
possible appearance in the sequel since
his first appearance a slew of different
Marvel movies have come out and Hulk's
nemesis hasn't reappeared on the big
screen why because Black Widow capped
him off screen in Marvel's official
Avengers tie-in comics to this day he's
just hanging out in a prison somewhere
completely forgotten by the Marvel
Universe what a way to go how dare you
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]